hey guys I'm just and you're tuned into
another episode of GameSpot news top 5
and I'm your only hosted a star let's
get right into it so city skylines
otherwise known as that game that was
better than SimCity according to a lot
of people is coming to xbox one on April
21 it originally came out on pc mac and
linux but now you can grab it on xbox
one including the first dlc expansion
but unfortunately not the others if you
are playing on pc there's a new
expansion for you to called mass transit
that's coming with a well a bunch of new
transport options the xbox one version
is coming with the base game and the
after dark expansion which is when take
after dark stuff so i can i tell a
twenty bucks get it if you want still
next door Mass Effect Andromeda got a
patch this week and if you haven't
played it yet and you've been waiting
for it to get passed you probably made
the right call because it's actually a
whole bunch better they've made massive
improvements to the way that eyes look
on human characters and sorry characters
they've let you skip the horrendously
long cutscenes that play when you're
trying to get from planet to planet they
made a bunch of changes to single and
multiplayer balancing the game has
Sudoku puzzle but answer their puzzles
but they seem a lot like Sudoku puzzles
you can go buy these decryption keys to
let you bypass them so they're gonna be
more available to you if you don't want
to play the Stoker's there are also more
patches on the way to do things like
improve cinematics and animations
apparently male roommates options for
male rider are not so great so they're
going to work on those two and I believe
those character credit improvements are
coming as well so this week Google went
and commissioned a survey to find out
what teens think is cool because I know
there's one thing you guys want to see
on top 5 news is to find out what teens
naked let anyway it turns out that kids
between the age of 13 and 17 think Xbox
is cooler than PlayStation but
interestingly Millennials which i think
is probably the majority of you ah
between the ages of 18 26 to 30 think
PlayStation is cool off there you go
unfortunately Nintendo is considered
less cool than both xbox and playstation
and by birth generations so it's not
1999 anymore the study was about what
brands teens think are cool in general
not just gaming brands so the ones that
came out on top work youtube netflix and
Google in general you're free
playstation plus games that are actually
free because you're paying for your
subscription are out now for april it
can't get the march ones anymore but
here's what you got on playstation 4 you
can grab the new release third person
shooter drawn to death as well as lovers
in a dangerous space-time on both
playstation 4 and video you can also
grab these two crossed by titles 10
second ninja and curses and chaos
finally if you're still on ps3 no
worries they've got you covered too with
invizimals the last kingdom and alien
rage extended the dishes this is
actually quite cool EA went and sent
free 2 terabyte hard drives along with a
set of one month subscriptions to e
access to people who have been with EA
access since the beginning for free as a
surprise and people were surprised and
they posted on twitter the one month
membership codes are designed to give
out to your friends so basically spread
the EA access love you've got an xbox
one and everyone can get access to
discounts and early access on games and
the vaults which now has 40 plus games
in it which was the whole point of
sending you the hard drive so you have
room for them all that's it for me do
you subscribe if you liked this video
and let me know down in that comment
section if you love it when we do
unscripted videos or you absolutely hate
it and wish it would be a script like I
do this is really hot we'll have scripts
again on Monday so come back and see us
dead
[Music]
[Music]